[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants au sport bonne et
heureuse année
patron je descend vite présenté mes
souhaits à nicolas n'y a pas preneur
je crois qu'ils m'ont préparé des
étrangers leur tous mes voeux nous
sommes pour moi patron prend pour moi
mon échelle au bosphore lui petit bonne
année et tous les voeux de mon patron
bien début je n'avais pas toi aussi tu
m'as jamais sans mon petit doigt me dit
que des gens sont très gentils
qu'est-ce qu'il dit un petit doigt quel
ques et bien mais c'est rennes ta pâte
rotariens données où il m'a payé mon moi
double eh bien nous et si on t'a préparé
une petite surprise ferme masure icône
jusqu'à 3
un deux ou trois sayaka au beau ce que
tu aimes mes pages panneaux regarde
seulement du mieux
oui deux biscuits au mieux
oui et du peu de puceau niel omon mais
ces [ __ ] ou des films c'est à
fortifiant jeu des potes l'huile de foie
de morue gros nigo c'est de la gelée
royale d'abeilles de la gelée royale
d'abeilles
j'en ai tellement besoin
ces fêtes de fin d'année ça fatigue et
sa menace
qu'est ce que c'est une tonne oui c'est
une bouteille de quoi donc quoi
d'hydromel monsieur nov de l'hydro me la
liqueur de tirs à la tête haute un si je
suis content je peux toucher à présent
oui mais à condition que tu ne manges
rien rien que du cac et un goncourt mans
produits les enfants je ne mange rien je
bois seulement un petit coup dit drummer
il est pour toi pour le marchand de
sable
l'une l'homme ça suffit ça suffit nous
lors
voilà ce que ceux où fait voir aux tomes
la moitié de la bouteille je garde le
resto pour le marchand de sable
olivier vous couchez les petits mois
j'emballe mes petites erreurs et jambon
beurre lui il ne fera ni nenê
[Musique]
bonne nuit les enfants à voici nounours
bonne année patron tous mes voeux de
bonne année
ma parole mais tu as been nounours tous
les patrons sont là pour vous elle est
vide nounours tu commence bien l'année
se te de l'hydromel patron le coeur de
dieu
ce qu'on m'a quand une bonne allure
je crois qu un peu d'air frais te fera
le plus grand bien
allons en route gro farseth roi auto ou
le poitou le patronat
[Musique]
oh